it's all about a used condom net Larry
no it's not alright I want to dive into
my meaning behind some of Sugar Ray's
yes most confusing there were rumors
about what this first lyric okay
[Music]
I know
see if I can use it father we get
[Music]
sorry mom the rumor was that the halo
used condom and everybody did you hear
that no this is this she told me this
theory and I endeavor and someone in
office was like yes I heard this too
that's true are you serious that's
correct that's what I mean that's that's
correct it's all about a used condom
Miller I mean okay look I'll be the
first about Sugar Ray but I would hope
that you know of all the rumors I've
heard that is the best and word at the
same time and I've heard a lot so what
is your on the road things the road gets
is little difficult relationships let's
put it that way okay and I think the
halo signifies in obviously you you have
an angel at home you know what I mean
and is it worth sacrificing what you
have for maybe doing something to
satisfy the immediate a much like
seventies lyrics had you know they're
they're very like sort of they were they
were like light and lilting but there
was like a depressing sort of dark
meeting behind it and that that's kind
of what's going on they're not about a
condom no
[Music]
that's Istanbul for me you guys are pros
okay that's the lyric I wrote my world
is falling apart
everything changes once you've lost
someone you love so everything you know
crumbles involved oh and I'm like uh get
a beer in the front row ik Oh
so I'm on stage singing this don't get
me wrong
yeah don't be we are a party down yeah
this one there's a lot going on here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is funny rigor this is really
really funny these lyrics are absolutely
incorrect
they're not even close they're not even
close because in flow and falls apart
which was I wrote that bridge part and
the melody I said to our producer there
are no lyrics in that bridge I did that
as a a rough sketch vocal and I said
David I'm gonna come back I don't have
lyrics this right now but I get idea
he goes go lay down right now I don't
great so I'll go well now you look
around him and then I can't be found
this table gotta be a my you know this
is little to me just feeling something
like I was talking about not even being
literal because there's no lyrics
it's me mumbling something but I could
never fill in the lyrics that that we
liked better and David's like you know
it sounds like you're singing something
how can we actually release this with no
lyrics livers and it's funny I see
people in the lyric sheets you know
online say what they writing they know
it's no one's ever got it right because
there are no lyrics to it it's literally
me mumbling a melody that I didn't want
to forget and that's what it is but
there are words you can pick out that
you can hear you know yeah and I'm
saying something but it's just it was a
stream of consciousness at the time I
think that's a perfect example a great
way to end this segment because lyrics
if they just give you emotion don't
worry about like the literal meaning
something that destroys you know what I
mean did you really want to know what
Roxanne's about we learned like a lot
about that's pretty hey that's funny
that that was like a great one to pull
out of there cuz that's an interesting
thing to haven't told a lot but I used
to be embarrassed about that is like wow
people are gonna like think that like we
really care about it but it's
interesting when you're home music you
just come from anywhere you know so some
people are out there killing themselves
trying to figure out these lyrics they
don't exist that's right they do not
exist but if there's a feeling that
exists feel it just like my knees just
like 'land I thought that might be your
tag you 90 feel it